laura amen joining me now is the man in
the middle of all of this right now
georgia governor brian camp governor
thank you so much for being here i got
to tell you just moments ago literally
15 seconds ago in my ear breaking news
we want to get your reaction
the all-star game has now been
officially relocated according to
sources
close to the associated press to denver
so from your state of atlanta
to denver colorado first your reaction
to that immediate news
well that's true pete thanks for having
me on uh
georgia has 17 days of in-person early
voting
including two optional sundays
uh colorado has 15. it's what i'm being
told
they also have a photo id requirement so
it doesn't make a whole lot of sense to
me but of course neither does joe biden
open in the
ncaa championship game tonight talking
about
ivory games played in indiana and what
how great it is and
indiana's the birthplace for the photo
id requirement in fact
the court case that upheld that was
marion county
where the game's being played tonight so
hypocritical
governor what is this about then because
those numbers don't lie it's obviously
not about the voter id requirement
it's obviously not about the number of
early days of voting
you've mentioned that the domain name
registered by one of stacy abrams
organizations
stopped jim stop jimcrow2.com was
registered even before
the bill was in its final form so why
georgia
why this line in the sand
well i think because we have an early
session and we took the initiative to
really fix some issues that we saw in
the
election last year and try to continue
to make georgia
state where it's easy to vote and hard
to cheat and have secure
accessible fair elections but i'll tell
you i think there's
several other things obviously you got
stacey abrams and her groups that are
including the president that are lying
to the american people and our citizens
and obviously
to a lot of these corporations that
they're trying to cancel
uh just for their financial well-being
you've also got
trying to distract from the people
flooding across the border
and then you also have the big push for
hr1 and sr1 at the federal level
to have an unconstitutional mandate to
take over
you know state elections
you're absolutely right i mean if when
the washington post
friend of joe biden is giving him four
pinocchios for his characterization of
what's happening in georgia you know
he's in trouble
uh it's absolutely not true but it's
just
not just major league baseball that's
the crazy part about this coca-cola
delta airlines delta in particular is
trying to distance themselves from this
law
but remember and i know you know this it
was reported that after you signed the
bill
an internal statement from delta's
corporate communications team to its
employees was leaked
the delta statement said its government
affairs team aka their lobbyists
have been heavily engaged in helping to
write the bill so governor
delta airlines was involved in helping
to write the bill because they wanted it
to be good and they were satisfied with
what it looked like now they're running
away from it what does this tell you
about the power of the left the mob
oh they're working on them you know
they're they're working on
the board members or the board members
themselves are working on the ceos and
i know some of these uh ceos that are
outspoken live in new york and new
jersey where
you know you have to have an excuse to
vote absentee you don't have to have
that in georgia
or they don't have early voting or they
don't have as many days like joe biden's
own state of delaware
it's so hypocritical and look it's just
unfair
to hard work in georgia and small
business owners and baseball fans not
only here but all across the country
that now this great sport america's
pastime
is now going to be politicized i mean
when i grew up playing
little league senior league high school
baseball last thing i thought about
playing those games and
having my family in the stands and a
bunch of other kids that i grew up with
was politics that's the last thing
anybody thought about
and now it's front and center because we
have a a bunch of spineless corporations
that won't just say
look we're not getting engaging in that
even though they've been engaged their
government affairs teams are engaged in
the legislative processes that work
through
and this is a bill that uh is really a
good bill it's gonna
you know further secure our elections
but also make them very
accessible every single republican in
the house and senate
uh voted on that bill and um it's it's a
good bill and they're just lying about
it i mean that's the simple truth i i
hate to say that but that's
that's the facts and there's plenty of
people piling on them now about
other things that make a lot of sense to
me like china and
in cuba yeah we're going to get to some
of that later on the program as well but
governor i know that you're on the right
side of this as far as the american
people ap just came out with a poll that
showed that 75
72 percent of americans believe all
voters should provide
an identification in order to vote and
of course your state georgia
offers one to anyone of any background
for free which i know you already know
and as a pesky detail the left will
always ignore governor thank you very
much
appreciate your clarity on this thanks
for having me on you got it great to
have you